[Music]
go to kuala lude app inshallah the app
tracks versus pages and time spent
reading and the verses to pages function
takes you from reading a few verses a
day to a few pages a day this project is
for the real enthusiasts if there's
enough of us out there this will become
the future of quran apps and support the
project if you can inshaallah may allah
bless all of you jazakallah
how are you guys doing
yes i'm joined with two very very
special men very very influential men
i'm joined with azusa and smile to janna
and ali
uh needs daoa
[Laughter]
how are you guys doing here i'm gonna
know how are you bro you're right here
alhamdulillah good to see you
um today we're going to be talking about
something very very important in fact
we're going to be respond i'm not
responding really she's saying reacting
you're so used to responding but yeah
good reaction there you have it there
you have it uh what's the name of this
channel how do you pronounce it kirk
craigslist
that sounds like you're having a stroke
in germany
if you've said this before ah it's
probably not yeah maybe
how do you say it you say
okay i like that okay actually you've
been you've started doing stuff on your
channel which kind of mimics their
material doesn't it yeah yeah they're
copying their stuff
no they're doing it in a better way
they're known for this kind of like
really kind of interesting uh
animations well put animations which
which are informative and
they give a little undertone of a very
kind of
atheistic liberal
backdrop
so i'm trying to agenda you're doing the
same thing but with with the islamic
kind of paradigm in place right
counteracting
not imitating uh going one step better
no i i i i welcome i think what you're
doing is really it's pioneering um
animations in the tao space and i think
that's really really good
but what i wanted to uh respond or react
to as collective right yes to respond
respond what i wanted to react to today
is um something i was watching about a
video they made about an antidote to
dissatisfaction and what was really
interesting was that some of the things
that they put
in that video relating to gratitude and
obviously from an islamic perspective we
have a lot to say about this because our
religion speaks about this at length so
the first thing i want to do is show one
clip okay about
what they're saying the benefits of
gratitude and then come back and have a
conversation
scientists found that gratitude
stimulates the pathways in your brain
involved in feelings of reward
forming social bonds
and interpreting others intentions
it also makes it easier to save and
retrieve positive memories
even more gratitude directly counteracts
negative feelings and traits like envy
and social comparison narcissism
cynicism and materialism
as a consequence people who are grateful
no matter what for tend to be happier
and more satisfied
they have better relationships and
easier time making friends
they sleep better tend to suffer less
from depression addiction and burnout
and are better at dealing with traumatic
events so as you guys saw there with the
first clip you know
it was talking about what the benefits
are to graduate what are your initial
reactions uh
i think my initial reaction is
that of
i wasn't really surprised yep because
whenever atheists or people without a
religion
want to encourage people to do something
either it will be done using threats
or it will be done using science threats
that we see
um traffic cameras yeah we see london is
one of the
the most yeah the hot spots one of the
most watched cities because of cctv if
you park in a bus lane you get a ticket
home before you've even reached your
home yeah so that's one way of doing it
the other way of doing it is by bribing
people through facts and through science
of science says the science says that
but just like when you watch these
atheistic debates and they they mock
theism or whatnot and then they get the
big clap and you know christopher
hitchens very well articulated arguments
but that's that's all they are they're
just well articulated but they don't
have any substance behind it so
when these people go home to their you
know empty flats and their ready
microwave
microwave meals
there's nothing of substance that's why
they go to the bowl that's why
christopher hitchens he admitted that
his his friend was the vodka bottle
uh so these people admit it and i don't
want to you know bait out other names
because it was made from the same thing
oh yeah mata rearrangement of of
particles
what do you think ali you were you were
a non-muslim at one point you became a
muslim
how has your life changed because of
islamic graduation to be honest like
cebu said really what i was discussing
with him he said atheists are people
that like they come in front of your
house and scream get out get out get out
and you run out and go weapon and they
go i don't know
they'll tell you no god no god no god
but when it comes to life from they said
okay give me a solution okay tell me
what's wrong with that um i don't know
why tell him to call my house then you
have nothing to offer me you're
intellectually bankrupt yeah you've got
nothing to offer you're intellectual
unique so the point is this you know
let's be honest you've got nothing to
offer so when it comes to gratitude yeah
it's what we're seeing here is it's good
because what it does is like the reason
i'm mentioning this is because people
like sam harris and new atheism have
realized this spiritual gap there's a
massive gap so they've even conspiracy
spirituality brother as atheists they
have gone because they've hit a wall now
it's good that we see that because now
they've read us they're making a u-turn
but what that means is in a nutshell
gratitude is good because now what
you're doing is like it says in the
video
happy be happy for the little coffee
that you have i'll be happy for little
stuff that's good that's the beginning
but we need to take it to the next level
because what this shows is a step f
towards the right direction which is
gratitude but now the question is what
are you grateful for because if somebody
gives you a hundred thousand pounds you
start and imagine you start the
money like oh thank you thank you what
about the one that gave you that you're
too focused on the money okay but we're
saying what about the one that gave you
that if you can find happiness and
gratitude with the materialistic thing
what about the one that gave it to you
if the material thing can give you the
happiness of being grateful for the
little things what about the one
who created you and the thing that gives
you the happiness what we're saying is
take it to the next level yes by
connecting to god because other than
that who are you grateful for or yeah
yeah
or what anything that the object of
gratitude is missing the ultimate
objective of gratitude
i think what you what you've mentioned
that's very well put and i think what
zushan was saying is i think something
they've realized as well because it's a
chemically reductionist approach i mean
now that and they've realized that which
is why in the nhs the national health
service in the uk for those who don't
know abroad
they they do have ssris like you know
serotonin um
or drugs that manipulate serotonin which
is one of the neurotransmitters right
um
however you know if you look at some of
the placebo drugs they have almost as
much uh effect as
as ssris which shows you a lot of is
actually cognitive which is why in the
nhs they put things like cbt cognitive
behavioral therapy or talking therapies
or um psychotherapies because they
realize this is it's reductionist to
just
kind of go all the way uh or speak of
this in chemical neurotransmitter in
terms of neurotransmitters and so on and
we as muslims our paradigm has always
been multifaceted
you know in terms of how we diagnose
issues it can be physical a physical
ailment it can be chemical of course
sometimes it is but also we have to
think about all the other dimensions as
well the spiritual dimension being one
of those things which is not even
accessible by the scientific method
it's a metaphor that you need to tap
into it's as simple as that
set those metaphysical laws in place for
a reason and this is this is the massive
gap that's happening bro you can be
grateful for coffee and stuff like that
you know but if the metaphysical law
what we believe in like the like the
process
um
wondrous is the affair of the believer
yes whatever like calamity strikes him
or goodness he's grateful or he's
patient i think we should stop with this
is very very important hadith well where
the prophet salallahu says
it's one of my favorite hadith in fact
that wondrous is the affair of the
believer in
that his
is grateful as well
and in that clipping that we just saw
the video clip we they were mentioning
uh they were mentioning how
people that are grateful on a regular
basis can deal with trauma better yeah
better yeah of course and this is you
know subhanallah is really showing us
the spiritual fruit of this hadith in
him
of course because if you think about it
when a disbeliever gets ill
yeah what well let's let's say someone
who is an atheist or a materialist yeah
yeah so if he's ill like the question
that needs to beg is
i would why am i ill why me what caused
it you have nothing
what meaning does it have yeah when you
talk about a believer it's like
expiation of sins yes um it's about
getting closer to allah
yes i've got so many options to choose
from now somebody come and say it's it's
um you made it up i don't care does it
work we know i know it's true but to you
let's suppose it's made up it does work
the formula doesn't work it's right
under our noses we're not seeing it and
we're not saying therefore god is true
it's not an argument for god's existence
we're saying that we are saying that our
systems
allows better quality of life that's why
i believe it is an evidence supporting
evidence yeah
this is supporting evidence but it shows
you that we have an in a yes propensity
an inclination to want to be grateful
to an ultimate source but
think of it this way if you come across
a a doctor in
in a remote kind of village somewhere
yes and you have a few illnesses yeah
you tell him look i i've i've been
bitten by this insect i don't know he
says okay he touches it and he's okay i
know what it is and he gives you a cure
and you're like where have you studied i
just you know studied somewhere
okay well i've got a rasha he prescribes
you a cure for it but he hasn't been
through the official channels and then
he gives you another cure when he keeps
giving you cures and they keep curing
you
eventually it becomes
illogical for you to say that no this is
he's a fake doctor oh yeah yeah yes what
you're saying is that islam is such a
robust and comprehensive system that
when you start looking at a spiritual
package
that is
in fact i would even say that if if
these proofs accrue this actually is in
favor of the truth of islam also so
there's a probabilistic type of argument
exactly exactly
yeah there's so many things if you see
islam through a social
through social life from a social lens
from a philosophical lens to a
psychological uh lens you will see that
islam
whatever it has said 1400 years ago is
relevant till today wow
and will be relevant in the future yes
and has been relevant in the past very
good in the past
it's a working model i want to show you
guys another quick clipping where they
give us recommendations of what to do
okay let's take a look at what they say
we should do
the easiest gratitude exercise with the
most solid research behind it is
gratitude journaling it means sitting
down for a few minutes one to three
times a week and writing down five to
ten things you're grateful for
it might feel weird at first so start
simply
can you feel grateful for a little thing
like how great coffee is or that someone
was kind to you
can you appreciate something someone
else did for you so they talk about
gratitude journaling what are your
reactions to them i think with gratitude
journaling we already have a form of
gratitude journaling
um
[Music]
yeah where it's in my head isn't it all
right
it's the biggest journal uh small people
can't see
yeah tell us what you're gonna say so in
in islam well let's look at psychology
they say
post the age of 25 is very difficult to
change the mindset of a person the only
two things that can change the mindset
of a person is number one trauma and
number two affirmations you're
constantly repeating something that's
why when you go to these self-help
classes or you go to a therapist they
say when you get up in the morning yeah
even people like j shetty they say when
you get up in the morning make sure you
don't switch on your device make sure
you
you don't do other things you say this
affirmation today is going to be a good
day i'm a strong person i'm a confident
person yeah and you give time to
yourself and that's exactly what we're
asked to do we get up in the morning
what do we say alhamdulillah
which please be to
has given us
life after death so we start off the
morning with gratitude lord we start off
with gratitude but instead of an
egoistic mother where it's all about
yourself now you have an object of
transcendence why and that's why i think
that's what makes muslims
you know we have
the key
why because when it comes to these sorts
of that's what i was saying initially
that you can tell somebody oh this
chemical is is released and that sounds
good in theory but is that going to work
when you are inundated with grief if you
are inundated with the trials and
tribulations of life no it does not work
and it will not work and the suicide
figures attest to that but when you come
to the islamic frame of mind and the way
of thinking
uh and and believing you will see it's
effective in so many different ways i
mean like you said
you mentioned that
in the beginning but the very first
thing that we introduced in the quran is
alhamdulillah
all praise and thanks belongs to god the
lord of the worlds and after each prayer
is sunnah or it's recommended at least
to say subhanallah which means glory to
be to god 33 times alhamdulillah which
is praising thanks be to god 33 times
and then 34 times saying allahu akbar
which is that allah's grace so you're
constantly in the day you are constantly
saying alhamdulillah that's a hundred
times in one prayer and there's five
there's five prayers so that's 500 times
and even one salah you the one thicker
that you're often repeating
so that is that is constantly you know
introducing to you if you put in
chemical terms although we're not saying
that this has got a spiritual effect but
even the chemical says endorphins and
neurotransmitters are really
but who is it too like it's very
interesting are you saying alhamdulillah
it's not egoistic okay no no i'm not
saying that yeah when you're saying
alhamdulillah whatever it may be yeah
it's like your gratitude is it to the
object but if you realize all these
thicket is around you to allah allah
what are they talking about it's all
about because they don't have that yeah
they have to fill it it's a form of
we pray for
is that if you think about in we have 24
hour day yes we're five daily prayer
yeah we have one week we have juma yeah
we have uh 12 months we have ramadan
we have a lifetime
isn't it amazing allah from our day to
our week to our year to our lifetime has
prescribed a little antidote that it is
there one way or another even the
victory you're talking about
every now and then even like you can see
in an hour the thicker allah has even
prescribed something
somewhere that
whatever it may be for us to work with
bro it's a system
and fasting is beautiful because it's a
practical way of withholding from things
which we take for granted
that's a really good food drink sexual
intercourse etc but there's more to it
than that i mean i think what you were
saying was really powerful in that it's
there's a hadith which says
whoever does not thank the people does
not thank allah so even if we're being
thankful to people and by the way isn't
saying
you don't say whoever thanks the muslims
this is this shows you the
comprehensiveness and the universality
of the islamic religion whoever does not
thank the people whether they're muslim
or non-people in the muslim if you don't
thank people who deserve that thanks
then you're not thinking a lot it shows
in gratitude but if you think about you
know what allah says we ordered you to
like well after worshiping us being
grateful to the parents as well yeah aki
someone has ingratitude to their mom or
dad yeah can never be grateful to allah
if you think about it if the one god
gave birth to you or the people if
you're not grateful to somebody who did
something good to you that shows a
disease of ingratitude in the heart that
could lead to in gratitude aggression to
allah so what we're saying is if someone
can't be grateful to the one who gave
birth to them how could they be grateful
to the one who gave the mother wow wow
you know there's another thing you can
say as well which is that it's so ironic
that we are using allah's air his oxygen
his material his time his space in order
to be ungrateful to him with it that's
the key
what you can add on to that also you
know when you sorry one more thing you
know abdullah and lucy you know you know
the brother he's he's made so he made a
really good point one time and i'll give
him credit for this he said you know
what it's like
he said it's like
um it's like someone who's for example
you've got you've got a wife and you uh
she's paying for you okay she's paying
for for all the you're not you're the
breadwinner she's the breadwinner yeah
she's the breadwinner she's paying for
food drink housing accommodation
everything right
what's a good wife then
right so she's doing all those things
right which is the anti-traditionalist
model the opposite of it even not even
the feminist model
so and so he takes the money okay that
she's paying him and all that kind of
thing yeah
and he goes and he cheats on her
using the money that she gave him
do you see the point here and this worse
using the money that's what he was
saying using the money and
it's the same as human beings the energy
goes and it's worse than that is a
billion times right if it was
say right so it's worse than that
because human beings we're using the air
we're using the oxygen we're using the
place and the time and everything that
we can't go anywhere to escape the
dominion of god and we're being
ungrateful to him in his own space
with his own spirit he's just hellfire
i don't care what anyone says you
if you truly comprehend
that what you're doing
there's no place except hellfire for you
i'm so sorry yeah you know one other
thing when when you want to charge your
phone there's youtube videos where you
can charge it using a potato yeah i've
seen that yeah
so you'll get certain amount of energy
from it you can charge it using a
battery pack yeah you get a certain
amount of energy from it then you put it
in the mains
that's when you get the proper energy
coming through
yeah so being grateful to a cup of
coffee
what does that mean
it's like getting the air it's like
getting it from the potato then yeah but
yeah yeah it's it's so low level isn't
it but then when you're grateful for
this to the source
what you're doing is you're unlocking so
much
yeah you're not you're not just in a
room but you've unlocked the house
you've unlocked the village of the city
and that's what islam is and
unfortunately muslims as muslims we
don't appreciate this we see
drips and drabs of research and and we
cling on to it oh serotonin or oxytocin
oxytocin and cortisol and and all of
these chemicals we're not slave to
chemicals
yeah there's there's research europe
sheldrick's on a brilliant book in which
he links a lot of these religious
practices to even atheism that
you know even atheists uh take on board
these things without even realizing wow
wow
it's actually a really good book and
it's actually doing another one also
and as muslims as believers sometimes we
don't really appreciate what we have yes
and i think that's that's very important
for us to do and these things i think
can actually improve our iman if we use
it properly and this is i think a good
place to end because you know and the
quran states this itself
that if you are thankful then i will
give you more allah is saying this to
you
if you are thankful
which actually in arabic is like lamb is
for mubarak it's for hyperbole and noon
is also for hyperbole so it's a double
hyperbole that i will certain most
certainly you know give you more you
know this is if you are just thankful
i will certainly give you more
inc if you're ungrateful then my
punishment as you were saying is going
to be extremely uh hadith it's going to
be extremely severe
and this is what i think is a good place
to end but in terms of call to action
what we can do in our daily life is and
i i try and do this with my family as
much as possible is
teach our children really to honestly
the young people need to know what are
we thankful for and you'll see the most
innocent answers that they give i'm
thankful for my hearing my seeing my
being able to the five senses my being
able to walk and you'll see that these
things that we get for free for the most
part
are the most powerful and priceless love
that you have
you know love you somebody that you love
or a heartbeat you have a heartbeat your
heart is beating involuntarily you're
not paying it you know all of these
things are just happening the system the
immune system is working everything is
working
automatically within your body and
there's so much to thank for and if you
can't think of anything to thank god for
then this is part of the problem and if
you can do it then this will be part of
your solution wassalamualaikum
you